entre les téléphones et leurs
applications l'écarter paiement sans
contact et les dizaines de mots de passe
qui nous relie à nos informations
personnelles jamais dans l'histoire de
l'humanité nous n'auront été autant en
danger quand on pirate al dans un
nouveau numéro de complément d'enquêté
diffusé hier soir france de s'intéresser
justement aux hackers qui menace notre
sécurité est depuis le début de la
pandémie nos habitudes numériques se
sont intensifiées et de fait les
piratages qui vont avec
et si on croit que les hackers ne s'en
prennent qu'aux particuliers il n'en est
rien leur nouvelle si privilégier les
hôpitaux ces pirates sont capables de
contrôler et surveiller et fausser les
résultats d'appareils médicaux à
distance comme les scanners ou les irm
je sais pas chez les autorités en ont
vraiment conscience aujourd'hui le
trafic mondial d'extorsion de fonds dans
le monde entier représenterait 1300
milliards d'euros par an c'est trois
fois plus que l'argent généré par le
trafic de drogue
avec ce numéro de complément dans quelle
france 2 réunit 1 millions de
téléspectateurs alors carte bleue mot de
passe faut-il avoir peur des hackers
[Musique]
alors ça c'était exceptionnel on va vous
montrer de trois images
faut-il avoir peur des hackers alors
guillaume genton qui connaît bien le
sujet dit non oui puisqu'en fait dans le
documentaire on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
de hackers qui s'attaque aux grandes
entreprises aux mairies qui
potentiellement peuvent détenir des
informations confidentielles après nous
à notre échelle individuelle je pense
que notre vie tout le monde s'en fout
donc alors la vidéo les pierres parce
que ya une grosse part à north en parle
sur la messagerie whatsapp tout le monde
dit on va pirater nos informations
personnelles et les revendre et c'est
notre vie elle intéresse qui franchement
quand c'est des grandes entreprises
je comprends que ça que c'est si chantal
c'est pas vrai par ici à quelqu'un qui
menacent de revendre mes mails portes
pour trois millions d'euros baky qui
qu'il ya du hac agents perso et du haka
jonglage version perso il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui seront détournés leur
adrien ouais ouais
derrière ils envoient des emails aux
gens en annonçant lors des scènes et oui
après derrière c'est ce qui est arrivé à
mon père ils vont chercher de l'argent
ils vont chercher jusqu'à huit ou dix
mille ans et ça marche
alors qu'hier jack et je crois que
tiffany a été hacké vous avez quatre
gares de lyon garde merci sur mon
ordinateur tout simplement et en fait
des jets en peignoir à ce moment là non
et j'avoue qu'il ya une petite partie
qui sors mon écran devient tout noir non
là il se rallument avec marc et bonjour
c'est hadopi vous avait été pris en
flagrant délit de streaming machin etc
et là je me vois en photo je me vois
deux minutes avant en photo avec la
moitié de mon sein sortie donc ça veut
dire qu'ils m'ont à quai ils sont
rentrés dans mon ordinateur
ils ont alors juste attention tous ceux
qui ont des plus grosses poitrines fait
gaffe benjamin est donc imaginez la
surprise avec la tête comme ça le saint
qui sortent et mons devant qu'ils ou
elles ont demandé de l'argent en échange
en se faisant passer pour hadopi 2 vous
avez fait quoi maintenant j'ai tout
étant j'ai éteint mon ordinateur est
maintenant sur toutes mes tablettes je
mets un morceau de scotch amorce un
morceau de gaffeur non c'est fou ça qui
est dg technique moi ma carte bleue une
fois non et ma banquière m'a appelé
quand je voyageais beaucoup à l'époque
elle me dit est ce que vous avez dit
n'ayez hier soir hong kong un dîner de
15 personnes
aj ben non je suis à paris bas si j'y
suis allé moi et l'addition et
l'addition était non non c'est vrai oui
nos cieux week-end alors indépendamment
de notre groupe qui a été attaqué le
week end à disneyland
on a reçu alors sauf si mon mari avait
amené une maîtresse mais a priori non et
on avait mille 1700 1800 ha non c'est
pas alors qu'il n'y en a qu'une c'est
quelqu'un qui ont pris cette anecdote
qui m'a jamais rien dit j'ai rien capté
comme cela n'est point week end c'est
pas la peine de la refaire je veux dire
c'est pas la peine de nous emmerder pas
ils sauront vous êtes bien comme ça
c'est comme ça qu'on aime aller on a pu
découvrir par exemple qui avaient des
hackers qui accueille notamment des
dossiers médicaux des informations
confidentielles et c'est vrai que moi
j'ai tard y est un garçon que je connais
qui a un centre médical il y en a qui en
fait toutes ces données et il n'aura
comme il fait derrière parce que s'il
n'a pas les données pour soigner les
clients comment il fait c'est fait ça
c'est impossible il a été obligé de
payer je vous dis et il a été voir la
police la police à dire on ne peut rien
faire c'est impossible où vous payez ou
bien vous allez perdre toutes les
données des patients parce que le
lendemain quand le patient revient il
sait plus ce qu'ils ont il sait plus qui
l'a donc ils avaient toutes les données
de toutes ses passions avec tous les
dossiers médicaux et forcément il a dû
payer la rançon et la police a dit on ne
peut rien faire et qu'il paye en bitcoin
ça peut être la version ils ne m'ont
jamais en euros ou en dollars s'est
toujours envie de com qui est monnaie
numérique le court maintenant c'est
trente six mille dollars pour un bicorne
donc ça ça a formé notamment à cause de
tous ces athlètes ça qu'on les regarde
et sur les dossiers médicaux
un mot-clé assez simple un clinic entre
aux cinq machines qui sont en france et
qui sont ouvertes
cinq matches il détecte et ça paraît peu
mais ce qu'elles contiennent est une
mine d'informations confidentielles
donc là on a accès à au nom des patients
à leur date de naissance
on connaît le type d'examen et puis là
on a la date de l'examen pour un pirate
les hôpitaux et les cliniques
ce sont des jackpots en puissance sur le
dark est un seul dossier médical se
revend entre 50 et 250 euros à l'échelle
de la france
la valeur du butin est estimé à six
milliards d'euros
j'imagine que qu'un banquier ou un
assureur peut être intéressé par ce type
de données c'est incroyable alors je
vous dis tu sais les trucs de fou et ça
arrive à de plus en plus les gens
l'oublient oui qui dit moi je suis pas
d'accord avec toi guillaume parce que
non plus moi non plus en plus il ya
plein de gens il ya une copine m'a dit
j'aime beaucoup guillon mais là il a dit
de la mer lorsque tu as dix ans par
exemple
l'exemple natif à venir là c'est sa
personne elle même jeu excuse moi quand
je te dis qu'elle passe à la télé ou pas
je pense qu'alors hakem les boules qu'on
la voit à poil sur internet ensuite
quand tu es quand tu entends l'exemple
d'isabelle quand elle te di sita banques
se fait pirater vous avez contenir tout
ton argent
comment se fait cette fois qui parlera
ton argent quand six états banques et
ses pieds en lice s'est pas saisie kelly
la seule info que je retiens de votre
intervention
si vous avez compris ce qu'il avait dit
isabelle bravo et merci de cette laideur
c'est pour ça dans son offre de vente ni
leurs voix le coin en train de faire
l'amour avec ta femme et bat aura quand
même les boules quand tu vas retrouver
les vidéos et que toute ta famille te
faire ça alors oblige elle n'a pas de
famille
c'était pour faire l'amour des mails
envoyés bien que ses papiers pour faire
l'amour il emplit il prépara comme ça
veut dire que quelqu'un qui est devant
l'ordinateur de tiffany 24 heures sur 24
et qui attendent qu'elle se met nu enfin
cesser ces sacs sont probants fatigué je
sais d'ailleurs avoir les coordonnées de
la personne mais non mais moi m'a parlé
de quelqu'un de nicolas mai dernier
je veux dire c'est qu'on voit dans le
documentaire s'attache toujours à des
organisations
si on est concerné super nes et javier
raison sur les petits commerçants sur un
groupe de presse industrielle
ils ont soit des gens qui peuvent bosser
pour eux des entreprises de sécurité
mais les petits commerçants
quand ils vont déposer plainte les
gendarmes et les policiers envoyés dans
le reportage totalement impuissant dont
qui payent rien de plus en plus de la
regarder us qui viennent sur les progrès
sont patrons de pme qui a dû payer la
regarder comment il a dû pays regardez
les gorilles du quai s'est retrouvé le
couteau sous la gorge une pme de 20
salariés à faire tourner et 70000 euros
de rançon a réglé en trois jours mais
lui a décidé de ne pas se laisser faire
et de négocier la première phrase et je
ne peux pas payer 4000 $ mais je peux
vous proposer 5 pour faire baisser le
montant de la rançon
grégory miotte du quai joue sur la corde
sensible
le côté petite entreprise familiale qui
n'a pas la possibilité de payer plus que
ça la négociation dure trois semaines 30
messages échangés et gentiment après
quelques tentatives supplémentaires on
arrive à se mettre d'accord sur les 5000
de cette négociation
il reste un sentiment étrange le
syndrome de stockholm 2.0 peut pas dire
qu'on commence à comprendre l'agresseur
mais ont des fois je me disais c'est un
business comme un autre
ouais je vous montre et un autre un
autre excès sera le dernier sur ce
reportage c'est plus fort pour moi le
reportage nous a montré comment certains
équipements des hôpitaux peuvent se
faire pirater comme les pacemakers et
les acteurs à avoir le droit de vie ou
de mort sur les patients gardent bon en
moyenne il y aurait six objets connectés
dans la chambre d'un patient mais il ya
un revers à la médaille
les objets connectés serait cyber
vulnérables là je vais le neutraliser
donc là il est bien complètement
complètement inopérant maintenant ce que
je vais faire je vais renvoyer des
fausses valeurs au second moniteur et du
coup on peut faire penser aux médecins
par exemple que le patient va bien alors
que c'est pas du tout cas ou inversement
en piratant des objets médicaux des
cybercriminels pourrait prendre en otage
des services entiers d'un hôpital
un pirate aurait donc le droit de vie ou
de mort sur le patient à cause d'
appareil vulnérable
l'incroyable états unis d'un chirurgien
qui s'est rendu compte que le patient
qu'il avait placé un pacemaker était
l'amant de sa femme
non et bien il là précisément que tu es
à distance bah oui parce qu'un mari avec
un pacemaker
c'est en tout cas c'est une bien belle
histoire mais franchement vous avez
toujours le don de m elle doit être de
faire la fête
comment c'était un spectateur s'il vous
plaît oui à 74 ans
moi je suis d'accord avec eux oui et non
à 24% which vous savez pas ce que radio
vous anime en 50 % les gens qui sont à
quai mais je vous ai site ya aucun
recours possible
donc vous avez plein de gens qui sont
quand même au bord du gouffre entre
autres les personnes âgées qui sont très
souvent détourné leur argent ou les
banques et qui ne savent pas réagir sur
salchaud comment faire pousser que c'est
une catastrophe ça un fléau mondial est
fou ça ça vient effectivement ce que
disait jean ça vient d'europe de l'est
on ne peut rien faire allez faire une
main courante sert à rien il ya aucun
juge qui s'occupera de votre affaire